les meilleures joueuses de l'aqim monde
canadiennes et américaines travailleront
main dans la main la meilleure solution
pour nous et à long terme c'était de
prendre années comme offre on peut dire
il y à un mois
la ligue canadienne féminine cessait ses
activités faute de viabilité
aux etats unis la haine whl existe
toujours mais son modèle d'affaires
n'inspire pas confiance dans ce contexte
un groupe de plus de 200 joueuses issues
des deux ligues a donc choisi de bouder
la haine whl pourtant prête à les
accueillir
l'objectif est la création de nouvelles
ligues professionnelles durables
donc c'est tout cas une saison qu'une
ligue arabe s'est passé ce qu'on suppose
quelques mots ça prend à 15 à 18 mois
c'est sûr que ça fait pas mais je pense
qu'il ya un peu de recul on sait c'est
plusieurs de l'avant non ce repas 6 snow
sauf a rien fait
les joueuses des équipes nationales
canadiennes et américaines continueront
de représenter leur pays durant cette
année dit sabbatique et pour se garder
en forme des matchs amicaux seront
organisées peut-être même une tournée
pour promouvoir le hockey féminin avec
l'ensemble des joueuses
pourquoi pas avoir quelqu'un qui rêve
une jeune fille qui rêve de donner ma
fille pour un pic est classé malgré les
points qui joue pour les canadiens de
montréal points qui joue pour team
canada
la ligue nationale de hockey explore ces
options sont nés puis au rock et féminin
demeure modeste mais la mise en place
d'une nouvelle structure pourrait
changer la donne c'est ce qu'on entend
peu à côté du téléphone mais en même
temps de faire partie ou d'avoir un
groupe qui viendrait nous soutenir comme
la ligue nationale c'est quelque chose
qui serait merveilleux au bout du compte
les hockeyeuses réclament simplement un
meilleur traitement et encadrement afin
de pouvoir gagner leur vie grâce à leur
talent comme les hommes auront les gens
qui nous supportent pour créer cette
ligue là de pouvoir jouer qui est
récompensée comment comment mérite
jean françois poirier radio-canada
mourir